mark what is your job as a sound mixer
on the hateful eight and what does it
entail and the production sound mixer so
the equivalent in the music world would
be the creative recording producer I
come each day I deal in close quarters
with all the performers the cast to
capture their original performance and
with the Quinton it's a very specialized
circumstance because I've been with him
for over 22 years we've done everything
from dusk till dawn forward we met on
desperado actually when he came in
cameoed and quits the only director I've
ever worked with where we've never
replaced a single word in
post-production on any film we've done
together it's it's a unique it's a
unique situation and it has to do with
cat with what we do but also in
conjunction with his commitment to
capturing the performance he sees that
day and that's going to be in a movie
period so that's what I do I captured
those original performances interesting
and what is the reason that he doesn't
want to change a word what he wants that
authenticity of that first but can you
tell me a little more about why it's
specifically done like that he he
believes it's part of his process he
believed it's pretty much old school too
he believes in the work that happens on
the day for example there's no video
village on a Quentin show there's no
video assist Quentin's in the room he's
sitting at the camera with the actors
side-by-side right there just like we're
sitting here right now and it's a it
builds a environment of support and
Trust for the cast and it's it's
hands-on for him as the director he's
not sort of to stepping and he's not
watching his movie on TV live every day
and that principle is applied to
everything else he looks for reality as
an environment to support the character
development to support the story arc
everything is about that what I do is as
I'm a musician in his orchestra
I saw a sideman session player and like
everyone else Bob Richardson the
cameraman or or Fred the other we we are
intensely committed to our instrument
but our instrument comes into full play
when we play in the orchestra together
and so Quentin is a real throwback to
old-school Hollywood
filmmaking his films may not be that for
people as they experience it but the
process is it's a he's a perpetual
student and we all are where we're film
we're film crazies and and he's the lead
film crazy and that you know every we
you never say scene twenty five seven
you know Apple Baker it's it's all God's
or you know there's always a game
there's always play this music on the
set there is this environment of
creativity and he's comfortable in his
own skin
and we all are as well he wants you to
bring your game it's it's there's not a
there's not an ego wall there's no fear
there's just let's do it
you know downbeat on one no rehearsal
let's go that's an interesting statement
so if he's comfortable in his own skin
then that's that sort of the tone you
know how they say stuff rolls downhill
so if he yes if he's comfortable then it
sounds like everyone else feels it's
okay to be that way as West idea the day
gets five dollars oh nice I like that
okay it's like it's bring it you know
but it's in context you know you you
there's joy in that and there's serious
it's a serious thing to you know we're
here that we're here to do this right is
the piece you know it's not we and we
should have a good time that but fun
does not mean disconnect fun means the
thing the work is the fun fun you know
so how much notice does he have to give
you well you change your schedule and
drop everything or or he gives you a
little more than that um he's been
incredibly generous in that I usually
have a six to eight month lead on
something coming down the road you know
this is gonna happen here want to know
can you clear your schedule and and I do
you know as we all do because it's a
unique place you know now I know Quentin
admits that his dialogue is not always
for everyone and that it doesn't matter
on you admitted yes are one of our
interns ieave us found it and that it
doesn't matter sort of the quality of
the actor but it has to be the timing
not every actor can deliver the lines
with the timing and the humor that he
wants so do you see any difference in
some of the preparation with some of the
actor
for his style of delivering lines and
filmmaking I think what I've seen and
this this has grown from the early days
to particularly last four or five films
I would say inglorious maybe Kill Bill
really but in Kill Bill and glorious to
me were sort of transitional films to a
different kind of filmmaking for Quentin
from my experience of dealing with I'm
gonna deal with a lot of different
directors but his his evolution through
my eyes was to let those characters
emerge in pre-production through a prop
you know rehearsal they all do a
read-through they'll be you know weeks
of you know for example on this film
they built a proxy set in Los Angeles
for three four or five four weeks of
rehearsals so the actress could actually
be in the environment for their
rehearsal wasn't the set we were gonna
film it was you know because that was at
10,000 feet until you're about Telluride
but it was a place for the actors to
find their characters in the environment
in which they're going to operate
because in many ways it's analogous to a
stage play they're all in the same
physical space River for almost
two-thirds of the movie and in
widescreen in this this ultra Panavision
format
it's a dramatically different approach
visually because unlike narrower frames
you're almost in a master type frame all
the time it the frame can include the
close-up the medium shot and the wide
shot all at once because there's so much
geography available and how you do that
how you do that aesthetically so the
whole sense of putting on a play like
performance comes out of that rehearsal
where the characters are at least
centered by before the actors with
Quentin in preparation that said the
true characters really don't emerge
until we actually start rolling film so
but the templates are their templates
they're like Jennifer Jennifer's
character was a revelation
but as revelation had happened when we
got there you know she brought a certain
kind of crazy that was and you know
completely original and I I don't know
if that was your experience but you know
and and it really took the other actress
now they had someone to play against
because you needed that needed that back
pressure
from her character for the other
characters to work and he knows that
he's got great instincts about that I
love what he does with casting and
particularly how the ensemble there's no
there are no egos on this okay and there
never are he doesn't allow it
interesting so even though it is like a
band let's say there's no frontman
that's sort of the you have a conductor
okay you know and you have a score I
call the script you have a conductor
called called a director so there it's
not a democracy there's a leadership
process but it's it's a collaboration
you know I want your best you know
artists to come together you know every
shots hand handmade so you know it
doesn't happen in a box it doesn't come
preset it's a hundred people working to
get that that two minute thing to happen
so it fits into mosaic so when we're
sitting alone in a dark room or with a
group watching the movie we experienced
these as real characters on a real
journey and written in the space and
time that but it's an illusion but that
illusion doesn't work unless you build
that on the inside you know build that
from the characters sound challenges in
Telluride versus the soundstage in Los
Angeles what were the two differences
great question
very different situations very different
telluride was all real environment you
know first we went there for snow but
had no snow for a really long time and
and so we had to compensate in terms of
what we would shoot when we'd go inside
more than we had planned to originally
it's those kinds of things or create
snow and it's 30 different ways of
creating snow mechanically you know and
each one has its issues and from our
side they're they're audible so how you
deal with that is in pre-production a
lot of conversations different kinds of
fan configurations the to the diameters
of tubes that blow have to be wider the
pumps did that blow them have to be
further away so all of the you know
minutiae of that prep has to happen so
that when you're there and on the day
your focus is on this not that so that
your focus is on the performance and
capturing us so so in Telluride you're
above 10,000 feet so oxygen everybody's
you know weeks before they adapt to the
altitude you're in sub-zero when you get
to work each morning it's between minus
10 and minus
20 before the Sun at the sky and at the
warmest part of the day might be 10 or
15 degrees Fahrenheit you're going to
locations that are not normally
accessible on foot so you're if you
would drive to them you'd ruin the snow
that has to be in the shot so you'd go
to a drop-off point and be on a
snowmobile to another point and then
you'd hike up a ridge maybe a quarter of
a mile with your gear on impact on your
backhand and you'd get up there and
settle in and everyone times times 100
because you're doing that but so is
everyone else
crane parts and just you know or they're
in there the night before so the
logistics are like intense very intense
and they're intense in an environment
that's very challenging to your body so
everyone had to sort of that's the
telluride part of this and the that
sounds difficult but it actually created
a kind of energy not just for us but for
the actors that they really had this
resistance of the environment that said
the gear the things you use the tools
the hammers and nails they're not used
to that kind of universe so you have to
have a lot of redundancy because things
will fail and you have to be very aware
of the impact if you work something in
the cold a piece of electronic gear and
then you bring it to a warm place
there's going to be condensation inside
so it's like a little rainstorm and your
electronics that are designed to make it
and stop working at the worst possible
moment so you don't do that you have a
set of cold things you have said of warm
things the cameras were built in 1979
for far and away and the lenses were
from 1955 you know from Ben Hur and
Khartoum so they had to reconstruct the
cameras down to the ground and then
rebuild them viscosity of lubricants had
to be adaptable to the cold so they had
to be less viscosity because it would
become more the the the lubricants would
go slower in that colder weather so you
had to I mean it's just hundreds of
those little details they built custom
2,000 foot magazines for 70 millimeter
because no one shot two thousand foot
magazines before so coin could do these
longer play like takes you know and so
the cameras had to do that but they had
to be quiet enough so that they wouldn't
create a problem for the dialogue so
there's a conversation pant
and Gregor tavern a who was Bob
Richardson's long-term you know camera
assistant and just all those details
have to be engaging so that's that's the
rough environment out there the stage
it's refrigerated it's 20 to 25 degrees
and they're pumping in humidity
ninety-five percent humidity to get the
breath that's why we're refrigerating
the stage even though we're inside you
have to know that it's always cold
inside and if you notice all that
breathing none of that CG I know that
happened in a computer that's in the
room that's everyone is you know even in
the stage very cold and in the stage
there's no real snow to be had so
there's a greater application of
mechanical effects for snow and it's an
enclosed space so the vulnerability of
the dialogue to that is much greater so
it's a constant collaboration with the
effects people the machines have to go
further away you have to turn it down a
little bit this is a very quiet piece of
dialogue but it's just what we did on
the set up before but it's not the same
because we're in a different physical
space the microphones are in a different
place we have to adapt even though it
seems the same that kind of
give-and-take everyday every shot every
minute and to stay on it stay in the
game you can ever sort of back off from
that and and it's it's never created
tension because everybody knows that
what you're doing is to try and dial it
in so that when the camera rolls well
that's disappeared and it's just the
space where the performance can handle
that's that's sort of you know our core
collective mission the the wind sound
throughout the film which was great
because I felt physically cold the
entire time I was watching it I did too
but not because of the sound it was all
my muscle memory honestly was right
right from being there and Telluride or
or the trip I just cold as an everyday
thing is it's a different perspective
you know you know why they drink so much
in Scandinavia a fresh source or to keep
warm and there's not really much you can
do of course when the weather's like
that but with the wind sound I'm
assuming a lot of that was all
after-effects that's you're not actually
a combination just some of it is about
helping mask some of the mechanical
stuff but but really and this was from
the outset Wiley statement whose
with Quentin since since Kill Bill
brilliant brilliant artist and Mike
Miller's the other trio of the three of
us that have been with Clinton for a
long time in the sound side of things we
get together before a movie we sat and
combed through the script page by page
line by line you know weeks in advance
of even the the scout pre-production to
look at brainstorm talk about approach
to this and wind from the very outset
was and this came from Quentin as well
it's a sort of a subliminal character in
the film this this blizzard that's there
as part of what's driving the stagecoach
forward and it's what's what you always
have a sense of the the death desolate
you know isolation inside minis because
it's always there outside so the wind is
kind of I don't know if you notice this
the music in this film compared to
Quentin's other films is relatively
sparse yes but it really isn't because
the wind is that music and the wind is
is being used in so many ways and Wiley
was so scale for this in terms of
punctuation supporting a moment having a
silence that's underlined as a silence
because the wind is there on its own it
was a very very design oriented piece
and we got material that's real wind in
the real place on the real days but it's
all it's all a con it's all a creative
construction around the story arc around
the character arc you know so if there's
something that this is true about almost
all the elements in pointless film
whether it's a prop whether it's it's a
piece of dialogue whether it's a it's
it's you know the timing of something
the music's all real the piano playing
happens there on the set in the day with
the dialogue he doesn't break it away
Jennifer's guitar is a real thing she
prepped for months with that and did you
know about the guitar by the way no is
there a story behind oh yeah there's a
story the guitar is a rare was a rare
museum piece from the Martin guitar
museum that was on loan to the
production and they had made about a
half a dozen Chinese duplicates of it
for the breaking piece right right so
we're on the day doing that
and she's playing the real guitar cuz
the tone and the sound of that guitar is
very unique it's a it's a you know one
hundred and forty year old guitar you
know worth tens of thousands of dollars
and for some reason for some reason no
one no one and Kurt felt so bad about
something no one told Kurt about that so
we're in take we're in that take take
one and Kurt shatters the real guitar no
and I don't know if you see Jennifer's
face when she goes if you see the film
again watch her face at the Qatar
shatter that's because she's seeing a
rare and irreplaceable museum piece
suddenly being shattered so everyone's
freaked out in that room except when
there's a little curl of a smile on the
corner of his lip because something
happened that no one could predict and
it was in Jennifer's performance because
that was a real a real moment and and
and the PostScript that's really great
about this is the Martin guitar people
got notified about it that I heard the
second hand but within a day or so and I
had to think two things one two things
they said one was do you need another
one and two can we have all the pieces
for to put on display at the Museum
please because it's such an interesting
story you really would like to you know
have that incorporated in our in the
story of our guitar history yeah so art
art is a surprise art is risk and and
sometimes you get a special thing what
might seem like a negative but that's a
classic Winton moment you know that all
the elements are there but something
unexpected happens capturing sound what
are you using it at some point are you
lab miking people I said you know but my
house is working my tools are like
hammers and nails okay I use I have a
broad palette of things and I I make
selections that have to do with the
tonality of the actor where are we in
context with the character how we
experiencing this character is a more of
an internal thing what you know where
are we and the characters are in the
story so I use all the traditional tools
I'll use Japanese might call the sank
and a
boom work frequently and shep since and
no Mons and I use a Danish lavalier a
lot made by DPA and also Japanese thank
in lavalieres and other tools many
different mics that that doesn't cover
it but it's it's not about technique
it's about context so I try I do and I
teach on this I you need to know all of
those pieces and how to apply them but
you need to not lose sight of that the
real key tool is the filmmaker the sound
man has to be a filmmaker
just like the cameraman has to be a
filmmaker has to understand the
directors intent and the context of the
particular situation and if you think in
those terms
it creates flow on the set you're you're
responding intuitively or premeditated
either way based on what's what are we
doing what's the shot what's the scene
where does it seem to fit in against the
other scenes you know how is the whole
piece of cloth going to be affected by
the choices I make in this particular
moment and they all have to have a an
integration you know I try not to come
with an ideology because the day I come
and think I know the whole thing is the
day she quit because I stopped learning
and I'm not open to what we're what
we're really trying to get to happen
here so I don't know if that that
answers your question but it's it's it's
an it's a really important piece to me
that that I don't come with a preset
notion of a pro so all of those things
are true but it all goes towards the
idea of constructing a sound a mix in a
moment that's a lot like playing an
instrument a musical instrument that
keeps us inside that character that's my
threshold when we watch it as an
audience are you believing that this is
this character and they're in this
environment having this journey
everything that we do supports that so
if there's a noise that happens that's
unexpected my threshold is did it take
us out of the scene did it take us away
from the character if the answer's no
I'm not as emotionally disturbed by that
moment because I know that the core
thing is being protected if it does then
we're in a conversation Quinton or
whoever the director is here's it here's
an exposure here's a vulnerability it's
it's sometimes it's just a look you know
and it's not a big conversation let's go
again you know because he does not walk
without having that in the can period he
just doesn't he's absolutely failure
cannot cope with persistence and he is
the most persistent a person I've ever
seen in a director seat and I love that
because that's how I feel
you